beautiful day at the beach not a cloud
in the sky not a bird in the air
maybe because robots creepy scary crab
like
[Music]
[Music]
this is the bin cross hexa robot and
it's pretty creepy
I'm pretty cool here's how it works
pair your iPhone or Android phone to the
six legged robot and you've got your
remote control in the app you can see a
live view of the spider crabs camera and
even record video of the camera feed
[Music]
controlling the robots easy turn its
head and he'll walk in that direction
and that's not all the moves it's done
it waves cheers and dances yes it really
really likes to go to plus it can
conquer many terrains including stairs
[Music]
what is the purpose of you to answer
that I caught up with VIN crosses Co Oh
Andy Shu for a walk on the beach a very
very slow walk on the beach so if you
want to explore experiment our current
robots you basically have to be a
roboticist even if you want to do a
simple task like movin arm will take
hundreds lines of code basically hexa is
a playground for developers it gives
them a way to explore robotics even if
they don't have the cash or engineering
skills and they're already teaching hexa
new tricks like how to turn into a bowl
and charge at a red cloth but for nine
hundred fifty dollars hexans gonna claw
at your cash but you know what we've
really learned here a creepy robot
spider is really not that creepy it may
even be the robot best friend you've
never had
[Music]